Приветствую, с вами Вектор Т13.
И в этом видео я научу вас простейшей системе анализа веб-ресурсов на предмет использования антибот или антифрод-систем.
Даже без знаний программирования, всего-навсего за несколько минут вы сможете проанализировать любой веб-ресурс.
И что еще немаловажно, вы сможете контролировать изменения этого ресурса и всегда знать, когда с ним что-нибудь происходит плохое.
Я имею ввиду плохое для нас, то есть обновление антифрод-систем.
И это очень важно, потому что иногда пользователи работают на протяжении нескольких месяцев, а потом резко у них все обрывается, и они не могут понять, в чем же, собственно говоря, причина.
Итак, представим себе абстрактно, что у нас есть...
То есть веб-ресурс DetectExpert, и нам необходимо на этом веб-ресурсе создавать мультиаккаунтинг, то есть использовать большое количество аккаунтов.
В первую очередь, с чего мы должны начать?
Мы должны начать с понимания того, кто находится перед нами.
А именно, есть два основных типа антифрод-системы, антифрод и антибот-системы.
Первый тип это публичные антибот-антифрод-системы.
И второй тип это самописные антибот-антифрод-системы.
В чем же их разница?
Надо на это очень сильное внимание обратить.
Дело в том, что публичные антибот-антифрод-системы, они элементарно просто определяются.
Фактически в 100% случаев невозможно скрыть, что используется какой-либо сторонний антибот.
Имеют открытые данные, то есть вы можете зарегистрироваться в большинстве из этих систем, даже без проверки к Know Your Customer.
Но если же система...
high-end,
то тогда, да, будет небольшой Know Your Customer, с вами захотят поговорить и по факту
просто лишь созвонятся с вами по
Google Meet и
пообщаются на тему того, зачем вам нужна эта система и на какой веб-ресурс вы хотите ее поставить.
Скажу по своему опыту, у меня не возникало проблем ни с одним...
ни с одной из антифрод-систем и, конечно же, даже несмотря на мою репутацию,
все компании выдавали мне доступ к своим ресурсам.
И когда вы уже попали внутрь, вы можете просмотреть полностью все и понять,
система базируется на правилах, система базируется на метриках, либо же система базируется на сборе третисторонних ресурсов.
Иными словами, все невероятно просто.
И мы всегда можем понять, что там происходит внутри.
Дальше. Четвертый пункт.
Вам не понадобится
деобфускатор джаваскрипт-кода.
Очень важный и скользкий момент, который я сейчас упущу, пока мы не перейдем к следующим теме.
И это была публичная антифрод-система.
Что же с самописной антифрод-системой?
Есть компании, которые не хотят передавать свои ресурсы
в пользование каким-то другим компаниям.
Либо же хотят даже сэкономить на этом,
или же полностью уверены в том, что их решение,
будет намного лучше, чем все, что есть на рынке.
Это называется самописная антифрод-система.
Вот этот зверь очень-очень сложный.
Объясню почему.
Дело в том, что когда используется самописная антифрод-система,
ее можно в большинстве случаев вскрыть так,
что найти ее будет крайне сложно.
В этой системе нельзя зарегистрироваться.
Соответственно, вы не можете получить какие-либо данные,
о том, что эта система собирает от вас.
То есть фактически, да, можно проанализировать фронт-энд,
то есть какие скрипты выполняются, что они хотят,
но для того, чтобы проанализировать, какие скрипты выполняются,
и что они хотят, пункт номер три.
Вам обязательно нужен хороший JavaScript диапускатор.
То, что абсолютно не нужно в публичных антифрод-системах,
в самописных нужно на 99,9% случаев.
И действительно, это очень сложно.
Это очень сложный зверь.
И сегодня мы будем разбирать с вами,
как анализировать публичные антифрод-системы.
А в следующем уроке поговорим уже о самописных антифрод-системах.
Для примера скажу так.
Для того, чтобы проанализировать публичную антифрод-систему,
нужно максимум час времени.
Для того, чтобы проанализировать самописную антифрод-систему,
нужно примерно две недели машинного времени,
и затем еще несколько дней,
я имею в виду где-то в районе 10-20 часов,
человека-часов ручной работы.
Это если повезет.
В некоторых случаях звери бывают настолько сложные,
что может уйти месяц и два на то, чтобы их раскрыть полностью.
Но поскольку мы живем с вами в пластмассовом мире,
публичных антифрод-систем намного больше,
в сотни, в тысячи раз больше, чем самописных.
Так что сегодня в этом уроке мы будем ориентироваться непосредственно на публичные системы.
А для тех, кто интересуется, как проанализировать самописные антифрод-системы,
вы можете перейти к следующему уроку,
в котором мы разбираем такое программное обеспечение, как Burp Suite.
И там я покажу вам, как проанализировать самописные антифрод-системы.
Ну что ж, от слов к делу.
Мы понимаем, что задача у нас не из легких,
но благодаря моему руководству вы сможете сделать это все элементарно просто.
Итак, прежде чем перейти на какой-нибудь веб-ресурс и начать с ним работу,
я рекомендую сделать следующее.
В браузере Chrome открываем вкладку Chrome WebRTC Internals.
Это штатный механизм, который показывает открытые WebRTC соединения.
И этот механизм,
невероятно важен,
потому что он позволяет определить,
когда действительно используются антифрод-системы.
Да, это звучит довольно глупо и тупо,
но, тем не менее,
это невероятно важный механизм,
поскольку без его анализа
вы не сможете нормально обойти веб-ресурс,
если будете использовать неправильные сетевые соединения.
И как работают эти механизмы,
мы рассмотрим чуть позже.
Итак, открываем наш первый инструмент, WebRTC Internals.
Далее, выберем веб-ресурс.
Я очень люблю показывать
своим ученикам пример с ресурсом,
который называется Chase.
Наверное, вы знаете такой веб-ресурс.
Американский банк.
Мы не занимаемся ничем незаконным.
Мы просто
с академической точки зрения
сейчас анализируем данный веб-ресурс.
Вы, как пример,
можете взять любой другой.
Я беру этот пример
сильного веб-ресурса
с отличной технической составляющей.
Итак, прежде чем мы перейдем на данный веб-ресурс,
мы нажимаем на клавиатуре
волшебную клавишу F12,
которая переведет нас
в режим разработчика.
И
переходим здесь на вкладку Network,
для того, чтобы
проанализировать наши сетевые запросы.
Итак, первое, что нам необходимо сделать,
мы переходим на сайт Chase.
Итак, и на вкладке Network
мы смотрим огромное количество
сетевых запросов.
Их реально много.
Давайте пока остановим их,
остановим лог,
и посмотрим,
есть ли здесь что-нибудь
для нас важное.
Фактически, вы сейчас наверняка,
как и большинство людей,
которым я показывал этот пример,
вы, наверное, сейчас испугались.
Испугались того,
что у нас здесь очень много
различных скриптов,
и нужно будет тратить множество часов
для их анализа.
Нет, не нужно будет, поэтому можете
не волноваться.
Здесь я хотел бы сразу обратить ваше внимание
на один простейший фильтр.
Он находится...
Где у нас момент?
Мы сейчас расширим нашу консоль.
Вот.
Вот наши фильтры.
И мы можем, в принципе,
показывать только третьесторонние ресурсы.
И у нас становится сразу же
много меньше
тех данных, которые
необходимо анализировать.
Но, как я и говорил, анализировать вручную
мы их не будем, потому что вот, например,
мы видим какую-то картинку.
И если мы, в принципе, по ней кликнем
два раза мышкой, то мы видим пиксель.
Не знаю, видно вам сейчас или нет.
В центре экрана у меня находится
черный пиксель. Один.
Вот он. На максимум сейчас поставил.
Надеюсь, вам будет видно.
То есть мы, в принципе, даже могли бы представить,
что это уже работает система
проверки канваса. Но не просто система
проверки канваса. Данный пиксель
может быть разного цвета.
А значит, в данном случае используется
невероятно простая система детектов,
которая позволяет определить
использование антидетектов путем
подмены канваса. Но сейчас не об этом.
Это хорошее
знание, но нам необходимо их
автоматизировать. Итак, возвращаемся
на наш
на наш чейз.
Мы видим, что запросов, в принципе,
не так уж много. Мы сейчас уберем фильтр.
Запросов, в принципе, не так уж много.
Сколько здесь их может быть?
Семьдесят семь
запросов. Вот они. Семьдесят семь
запросов. Причем часть
из них это действительно части
веб-ресурса, какие-либо
визуальные элементы и так далее.
Здесь запомните раз
и навсегда. Антифрод-системы
не включаются
просто так. Они включаются
по определенному триггеру.
По триггеру критического действия.
То есть, когда вы просто перешли на веб-ресурс,
этого мало.
В большинстве случаев
не будет работать антифрод-система
на полную силу. Будет работать антибот.
Вот даже, смотрите,
у нас на WebRTC
вкладке у нас нет никаких сетевых
соединений. Поэтому,
когда вы производите логин,
когда вы производите регистрацию,
когда вы производите восстановление пароля,
пополнение счета, снятие со счета
и так далее. В момент
таких критических действий именно это
когда и включается антифрод-система.
Давайте мы сейчас
разрешим наш фильтр.
Перезагрузим
страницу. Кстати, на всякий случай
я сейчас перезагрузил фильтр
и если вы захотите проверять антифрод-систему
не забывайте делать
следующее. Переходим
здесь на вкладку cookies
и
удаляем cookies. Это очень важно.
Потому что антифрод-система
может не включаться, если
она вас уже видела до этого.
Поэтому обращаю на это ваше внимание.
Итак, перезагружаем наш
веб-ресурс. Видим огромное количество
запросов. Ну что ж,
попробуем совершить какое-либо критическое
действие. Вот здесь нажимаем
забыли пароль. То есть даже не
регистрация, а забыли пароль.
Итак, смотрите, сколько у нас здесь
запросов. 198 уже.
Посмотрим,
что здесь есть интересного.
Давайте остановимся сейчас
и, ну вот, даже 200
запросов. Хорошее число.
Мы не будем сейчас
совершать
какую-то магию. Мы просто нажмем на вот эту вот
кнопку export
har. И
когда вы нажмете на эту кнопку,
все запросы с данного веб-ресурса
они сохранятся в
отдельный файл. Я
остановлю сейчас лог.
После того, как мы сохраним эти
запросы в отдельный файл,
мы можем их проанализировать уже
совершенно другими средствами.
Автоматизированного
анализа
джаваскрипта и веб-ресурсов.
В частности, если мы будем смотреть
вручную. Вот здесь давайте
почему я люблю Chase.
Здесь очень классно можно найти.
Например, смотрите.
Вот запрос сканирования порта
5902. Вот
5939.
5939 это порт Teamviewer,
если не ошибаюсь.
7077 и так далее.
То есть, или вот. Или это порт
Teamviewer. Ну, не суть. Важно.
Например, сам веб-ресурс сканирует
наши порты. А если мы возьмем и
поставим фильтр третьесторонних
веб-ресурсов, то мы видим
здесь запросы к веб-сокету.
Но, помимо этого, мы видим здесь
запросы, например, к
к к к
сейчас хотел вам показать.
Вот он запросик.
Посмотрите на него сейчас.
Это запрос к
веб-ресурсу OnlineMetrixNet.
Что соответствует
антифрод-системе ThreatMetrix.
И подтверждение этого
мы видим даже здесь, на вкладке
WebRTC Internals, где у нас появился
запрос
к серверу
aaonlinemetrix.net
В данном случае используется,
например, и TCP-подключение,
и UDP-подключение.
И, например,
забегая вперед скажу, сайт
Chase в данном случае
выполняет процедуру пинг-понга.
Что такое процедура пинг-понга?
Есть
несколько видов подключения
с помощью WebRTC. Есть подключение
типа STUN.
Давайте сейчас проверим,
чтобы была ясность.
Вот у нас подключение
типа STUN. Видим браузер
Leaks, STUN-сервер Google.
Окей.
STUN-сервер можно так назвать его по-простому,
хотя меня за эти слова можно
поругать. Это как сигнальный сервер.
То есть этот сервер,
сигнализирует о том, что можно
установить в WebRTC соединение
по определенному адресу.
Все. Но фактически он
это соединение не выполняет.
Поэтому
очень просто данная технология
обманывается. Можно
подменить себе STUN-сервер
на IP-адрес свой,
на любой другой. И, в принципе,
это все прокатит.
Но в случае с Chase используется
не STUN, а TURN протокол.
А значит, что благодаря
TURN протоколу устанавливается
соединение. И, в частности,
здесь установлены соединения TCP
и UDP.
Когда вы видите с помощью
WebRTC Internals, что используется
сервис
ThreatMetrics, в данном случае представленный
доменом AANlineMetrics,
можете
100% быть уверены в том,
что если ваш проксик не поддерживает
UDP протокол,
то вы обосретесь.
В 100%.
И плюс ко всему, необходимо
правильная система прогрессификации.
Почему? Потому что, как я и говорил ранее,
здесь используется система PingPong.
PingPong
устанавливает соединение TCP,
устанавливает соединение UDP,
а затем производит запрос-ответ,
запрос-ответ, запрос-ответ.
Таким образом, они
получают анализ
пингов, анализ скорости
ответа, и, в частности,
могут понять, если вы находитесь, например,
за пределами США,
если ваш IP-адрес, к примеру,
отвечает очень-очень медленно,
как один из вариантов.
Второй вариант, если ваш IP-адрес
не поддерживает UDP протокол,
то будет только лишь
установлено TCP-соединение,
а UDP-соединение установлено не будет,
соответственно, 100%
признак использования прокси.
Но это с того, с чего
нужно начинать. Итак, пойдем дальше.
Вот наши все запросы
от Chase.
И, как я и говорил, мы здесь видим и анализ
портов, и всего остального, но
как нам проанализировать весь этот
объем информации? Очень
просто. Для этого нам всегда на помощь
приходит чат GPT.
Я не
сторонник использования данного
веб-ресурса, хоть и постоянно
о нем говорю. Я объясню, почему этот
ресурс мы используем.
Дело в том, что
это средство
просто автоматического анализа, которое
причем нам может очень часто врать,
это понятно, но иногда
если у нас нет знаний в определенном
из языков программирования,
или же нам нужно просто автоматизировать
какой-то простейший процесс, данное
средство является очень важным в нашей работе.
И лично я его использую часто,
хотя, конечно же,
делиться какими-то чувствительными
данными, либо своими разработками с ним
я не собираюсь, потому что
увы, данный веб-ресурс
лично для меня
доверенным не является.
И, конечно же, как было заявлено,
он может использовать все эти данные,
против нас, и я не хочу, чтобы
мои какие-то авторские разработки
затем были
украдены.
Ну, факт есть факт.
Но, тем не менее, проанализировать файл
har, который мы сохранили,
можно всего-навсего за 8 минут,
вот у меня анализ занял всего-навсего
8 минут, и мы видим, что у нас используется
система LexisNexis.
Я перейду сейчас на англоязычную
версию данного анализа.
Итак, у нас используется
подключение к серверам
ThreadMetrics, что является
сигналом того, что
используется система LexisNexis.
Далее, что мы не увидели?
Мы увидели ThreadMetrics, но есть
то, чего мы не увидели, например.
Chase CDN.
Казалось бы, CDN
Content Delivery Network, ничего здесь
особо важного нет. Но
каким образом данные
веб-ресурсы доставляются до клиента,
этот способ позволяет
проверить метрику
уже со своей стороны, не со стороны
ThreadMetrics, а со своей стороны.
Иными словами, можно понять,
что конкретно,
какой конкретно
латенси используется, какой джиттер
и так далее. То есть, да, опять же
определение прокси.
Данный веб-ресурс, как мы видим сейчас,
он направлен в первую очередь
сейчас, получается, на проверку прокси.
Идем дальше.
Следующий наш инструмент
это инструмент Dynatrace.
С данным
инструментом, наверняка,
многие из вас не знакомы,
но это анализ
производительности.
Анализ производительности, то есть
скрипты, которые позволяют
проверить производительность
нашего ПК.
И, в частности, это необходимо
для определения использования ВПС,
для определения использования
удаленных серверов, для определения
использования виртуальных машин
и также
для определения использования браузерных
антидетектов, в том случае, если они
заявляют, например, о поддержке WebGPU,
хотя самой поддержки
по факту они не производят.
Далее.
Akamai.
Akamai заслуживает отдельного урока, который
вы сможете посмотреть позже.
Akamai самый крупный игрок
на
рынке антифрод-систем.
И крупный он за счет того,
что у него есть огромное количество
серверов.
На текущий момент, если не ошибаюсь,
у них чуть более 280 000
серверов по всему миру.
А это означает что?
А это означает, что вы
находитесь, например, во Вьетнаме.
Пример. Город Дананг.
Великолепный морской
курорт, я его очень люблю.
И вы используете прокси
США. Вроде бы
ничего плохого. Но, как
вы думаете, если
производить проверку
с помощью тех же самых
ПИНГов, про которые мы говорили ранее.
ПИНГ веб-транспорта,
как вариант. ПИНГ UDP,
ПИНГ TCP. И производить эту
проверку,
например, из серверов
Вьетнама, Таиланда, Лаоса
и Китая. Какие показатели
будут. И в то же время, если мы
будем производить ту же самую проверку
из серверов США
к вам.
Как вы можете понять, то
благодаря такого рода проверке
есть возможность определить,
что пользователь находится
не на территории, на которой он
заявляет. Использует средства
скрытия своей локации.
Данная методика
работает очень даже неплохо.
Но, конечно,
очень быстрые прокси
позволяют в большинстве случаев
проигнорировать. То есть, просто
хорошее интернет-соединение и
быстрые прокси это, я вам так
скажу, залог большинства
успехов. То есть, если вы
используете какое-нибудь соединение
типа даже 100 мегабит, ну, задумайтесь
о том, чтобы перейти
все-таки на хотя бы
соединение скоростью в 1 гигабит.
Вы сразу же увидите, как ваши
проблемы с антифрод-системами
они значительно уменьшатся.
Я, конечно, знаю, что
есть некоторые люди, которые
по каким-то непонятным причинам, может быть
по религиозным, может быть по ментальным,
они пытаются работать с 3G
модемов.
Каждому свое.
Но я лично вам такого не советую.
Итак, мы видим, что
используется система Akamai.
Система Akamai также
еще позволяет проверить
репутацию IP-адреса.
Что это означает? А это означает, что
если на ваш IP-адрес
с него какая активность была?
Если с вашего IP-адреса
загружались обновления для Windows,
если с вашего IP-адреса загружались
какие-нибудь торренты, какие-нибудь
программы,
обновления
офиса, например, или же
чего-то еще, это классно, это хорошо.
Если с вашего
IP-адреса совершалась
активность по просмотру онлайн
кинотеатров, а там тоже участвует
Akamai, то есть в том же самом
Netflix работает Akamai,
для того, чтобы доставить контент.
Соответственно, активность
с вашего IP-адреса, она легитимная.
А если ваш IP-адрес
включается на 1 час
времени работы в сутки
и не загружается
абсолютно ничего, кроме нескольких
веб-ресурсов, а мы видим,
что в данном случае Akamai ведь
у нас видит, что мы посетили сайт Chase,
и все остальные ресурсы, на которых
используется Akamai, тоже могут
Akamai может видеть
все остальные ресурсы, на которых
он используется, что мы их посещали.
Соответственно, активность
такого IP-адреса будет уже
подозрительная, и к нему могут быть
применены санкции. Поэтому
самый простой вариант, как это
избежать, поставьте себе
IP-адрес на ваш роутер,
например, или на обычный
ваш компьютер, и просто
прогревайте его таким образом,
что вы играете в игры,
смотрите YouTube и так далее.
Вы таким образом буквально за несколько
дней сможете из
плохого грязного IP-адреса
получить чистый,
хороший и приятный
в использовании IP-шник.
Но возвращаемся опять же сюда.
ChatGPT дает нам возможность
посмотреть все, что находится
на данном веб-ресурсе, но
только лишь из нашего
хар-файла.
В частности, я
показывал вам пример с Canvas.
Мы видим, что он его здесь
не обнаружил, правильно?
Запомните это, это довольно-таки
важная деталь. Потому что, когда вы
составляете запрос для данного
веб-ресурса,
он не всегда
может проверить все скрипты
самостоятельно, и ему нужно
будет об этом сказать.
Но, возвращаясь
теперь к нашему
сайту Chase, что я
еще рекомендую вам сделать?
Вот после такого простейшего анализа
можно получить множество информации.
Но если вы
составите такой анализ,
такие хар-файлы
для каждого из критических действий,
то есть, смотрите, как делаю я на практике.
Делаю хар-файл,
когда перехожу на веб-ресурс.
Потому что можно определить использование
антибот-системы. Делаю хар-файл,
когда я регистрирую аккаунт.
Делаю хар-файл, когда я
восстанавливаю пароль. Делаю хар-файл,
когда мне нужно привязать карточку,
например, или завести деньги.
То есть, фактически, один
веб-ресурс у меня может быть представлен
семью, восьмью,
десятью различными хар-файлами.
Затем, эти хар-файлы,
в моем случае, я загружаю их на сервер
для дальнейшего слежения за
веб-ресурсом, но в вашем случае,
если вы не хотите иметь серверную инфраструктуру,
сделайте очень просто.
Загрузите себе,
потратьте пять минут своего времени
для того, чтобы сделать вот такие
семь, восемь, десять хар-файлов
и сохраните их
себе на компьютер. Затем,
если вдруг что-нибудь изменится
на данном веб-ресурсе, и у вас,
например, резко упала ваша
производительность, составьте еще
раз хар-файлы. Получите еще
раз пять, шесть, семь,
десять этих хар-файлов. После чего,
с помощью того же самого чата
GPT вы можете их сравнить. Но я
бы рекомендовал использовать другую
утилиту. Другая утилита называется
CodeCompare. Вы можете использовать
ее. Я лично привык использовать ее.
CodeCompare.
Ну вот, div-чекер, может быть, или же
просто
сама программа.
Вот она.
Вот то, что использую я от компании
DevArt. И вы можете
сравнить, что изменилось
в веб-ресурсах
на этапе логина, либо же на
этапе завода денег. И вы
всегда сможете найти разницу
и понять, на что вам стоит обратить
внимание. По факту
скажу так. Анализ
веб-ресурса,
вот тот, который я вам показал, он очень простой,
примитивный, детский.
Но, тем не менее,
его хватает на большинство
веб-ресурсов. Поскольку
мы можем определить еще
чуть-чуть дальше, мы с вами узнаем
в следующих уроках, как определить
использование счетчиков
производительности, например, на
веб-ресурсе. Как можно
определить, что веб-ресурс использует
метрики WebGPU, WebGL
и так далее. Но для первого
шага вот этот
простейший алгоритм, который
позволяет проверить WebRTC,
который позволяет проверить наши сетевые ресурсы
и даже в некоторых случаях
позволяет проверить, где вот у нас
наш Canvas делся.
Давайте найдем его. Используется он.
Вот он. На третьем. Видите? Наш Canvas.
Опять же, квадратик этот
увеличен у меня на максимум.
Ну да, больше не увеличить его.
Но, тем не менее, мы
о его присутствии уже знаем. Canvas
можно определить, в принципе, элементарно просто.
Даже здесь невооруженным взглядом
можно
выставить
фильтрацию по Image.
И вот мы видим наш Canvas.
То есть никакой
особой проблемы в этом нет.
Вот этот ресурс какой-то у нас есть.
Смотрите. Сетевой. Давайте мы его откроем.
Вот здесь вот тоже
используется небольшой
ну это не один, конечно, пиксель.
Это не один пиксель был предыдущий.
Но тоже небольшое поле, которое
скорее всего используется как раз для той же самой
цели, для которой используется
и вот этот вот черный квадрат.
А именно определение
использования антидетектов. На всякий случай
скажу вам, как это работает.
Берется поле. Например,
пусть это будет поле, как в данном случае.
Сколько здесь у нас пикселей?
Мы можем это посмотреть.
Мы не видим сколько
у нас пикселей. Давайте представим себе, что
это поле у нас
50 на 100 пикселей.
И
это поле заливается одним
определенным цветом.
Это может быть белый, может быть черный, синий,
голубой, без разницы какой это будет цвет.
И затем
анализируется на предмет того,
были ли изменены
какие-либо пиксели. То есть
было ли изменение в цвете
или в альфа-канале.
Таким образом, можно определить, что используется
система подмены канвасов.
Так что, на всякий случай,
обращаем на это внимание.
Вот эту технологию вы будете видеть очень часто.
При этом, как вы можете
посмотреть, здесь вот интересно я вам покажу.
Здесь нет никаких
эффектов, здесь нет никакого текста.
Как, например, есть на Gmail.
Соответственно,
они не используют в данном случае
технологию получения отпечатка канваса.
Потому что здесь его не получить.
Здесь нет эффектов, нет текста.
Ничего. Просто заливка цвета.
Но, благодаря вот этой
простейшей технологии, они могут определить
использование антидетектов, потому что
антидетекты внесут шум
в данный пиксель.
На этом мы
заканчиваем наш сегодняшний урок.
Большое спасибо за внимание.
А если вы хотите проанализировать
веб-ресурсы намного
глубже, то смотрите
следующий урок, который позволит вам
научиться работе с
великолепным программным обеспечением
Group Suite.
И позволит рассмотреть самописные
антифрод-системы.
Спасибо за внимание. С вами был Вектор Т13.